everyone this is ben and emil this is
our finance team we brought you want to
talk about this a tick tock that went
viral this week he deleted this after
because it went so viral oh good we love
a shame a shame delete yeah so a few
years ago me and my friends started
making a spreadsheet breaking down our
incomes and availability for travel you
have your friends broken down here from
sean my top earning friend who makes
over five million dollars to who we call
broke bobby who makes 125 000.
how much available okay time off bonuses
how much we're willing to spend on a
three day trip seven day trip marital
status willingness to travel to a third
world destination split a private flight
and if they're degenerate gamblers or
not yeah man it's not awkward at all
when four of you go and they're like why
didn't you oh well because of the list
you don't really have that much money
yeah so we just didn't invite you yeah
broke bobby should come out and reveal
himself and be like i'm broke bobby yeah
help me i only make a hundred and twenty
a year probably
broke i don't know why people aren't
putting a trash can through storefront
windows after this this is horrible rich
people are so out of touch this is
insane he thought this was going to be
relatable guys if you want to make a
spreadsheet for you and your insane
friends we should do one way poor people
are friends and hot dogs how many oh
this is a list of all the hot dogs
and this is their marital status just
yeah
it's helpful to know how much we like to
gamble yeah just as part of it just like
and and shitty bobby likes ketchup only
do we know what these guys do it can't
be anything good this is what this guy
does he
like buys section 8 housing no yes wait
section 8 housing is it's like
government-funded housing for
how can you come people you can buy that
yeah took some old section 8 and flipped
it into like oh so he buys section 8
housing and keeps it affordable yeah
exactly yeah that's great no he buys
section 8 housing puts wood floors in
and charges eight times the rent i don't
think he makes it more expensive maybe i
don't know i was reading some comments
oh yeah no he would he would definitely
not make it what's he making three mil
three million what a loser investor with
380 rental houses
wow
[ __ ] if that tells you anything about
real estate you need 380 rental houses
to make three i guess i gotta shoot yeah
wow that's really that seems low for i
have to own half a suburb guys that's
why i have to be nicer to landlords it's
not that they're mean people they just
have too many properties and they're
going through a tough time right now
yeah and no one's thinking about them
his first video is how to buy a new
lambo online
the thing that pissed me off most was
the way that he was sitting on the couch
oh yeah like head fully wrestling like
this like look at all my friends look at
the millions of dollars we make you
don't even have the decency to sit the
[ __ ] off well when you're making a tick
tock sit up dude
it's disrespectful what are you yeah
look at the [ __ ] millions he broke
bobby he's a little [ __ ]
[Music]
no it's cause stop dude that's because
his boner was holding up the laptop yeah
but his boner is even harder when he's
talking about his broke that's why the
screen adjusted in the middle of the
tick tock yeah cause it got even harder
when he saw how poor his friends were
this broke box
the thing is broke bobby is not the
brokest they there's a they keep a list
of the bottom 10 earners wait so brooke
bobby's not a bottom 10.
bobby's a top but just me bobby's he's
he's like he's the bottom 10 income
earners in my friend group they call
themselves the welfare 10.
really good friends know most these guys
since college a couple of them
unemployed all of them under 100 000 per
year a lot more pto options expected
bonuses not so much
we don't even do a seven-day trip here
it's mostly three-day trips a couple of
them already tapped out fiance singles
you know kind of a mix there they're all
willing to do their world destinations
up there
you know kind of change up the questions
here non-chain restaurants very
important understand very poor ability
to do first class for hotel or flights
having points important and we have a
few degenerate gamblers here as well a
big thing to note i don't care about my
friend's income it's just very helpful
when we're planning day trips or road
trips and see where everyone's at you
know money-wise so i don't that's the
bottom ten i don't understand like they
could have just made that list and not
included the income and it would have
been the same thing yeah like just say
how much you're willing to spend on a
trip that's it that's all you need to
know this guy's in the welfare he's at
92 000 yeah wait 92k you can take a
week-long drink yeah hold on his name's
[ __ ]
handsome rob
these guys suck just based off their
names yeah i don't know what about this
guy ugly poor jake the second no i'm
kidding
jake
yeah
robin ryan oh ramen ryan is unemployed
why isn't rom and ryan at the bottom of
the list
yeah why is unemployed oh probably
because he makes more unemployment than
[ __ ] yeah he's got a decent jeez gimp's
a [ __ ]
get fired this guy even know these other
guys he knows me as a financial advisor
buddy you got to call your boss a [ __ ]
face
i think that that disqualifies you for
unemployment
[ __ ] face oops yeah
oh man we can get fired ah guess i gotta
go unemployment [ __ ] you dip [ __ ] you
can't get unemployment if you call me a
[ __ ] face oh
can i have a raise
they're all are they all just eating at
chain restaurants i thought it was a lot
of no's right oh i think i think that's
not because they're poor that's just
because they like chili's
need to rise up
against
the top one guy yeah and just be like
also this guy should just pay for their
just take him out he's willing to spend
a hundred grand on a trip yeah if i was
the world camp i'd be like
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah just give me
some money like is that really that
taboo just give it to you or
you have way too much i have that's not
the welfare list why don't you guys give
us some welfare bring us on a trip cool
it down
trickle it down make it rain on me i
don't care
knowing the the sick [ __ ] in the top
ten they'd probably be like it's
probably piss related to them yeah
trickle down you know oh yeah i think
they're pissing on i think they're
pissing on their friends yeah i'm
imagining that like the top guy rob or
whatever and [ __ ] go on a trip together
because they're both degenerate gamblers
they both say yes that's where they
connect but they have different you know
limitations
i imagine rob just betting 25k a hand
in front of [ __ ] and give him
dude just give it this to me
maybe his name is actually pronounced
jimp
the original guy could be this these
guys landlords which is the saddest part
he might be asking his tenants if they
want to go on a trip and he's like you
guys are so lame we want to go somewhere
fun oh my god and all we can do is road
trips and day trips which you then they
go on the trip and he wins a [ __ ] ton of
money in monaco he comes back and he's
like yeah you guys got to move out i'm
[ __ ] upgrading the section a place
you all got to get the [ __ ] out of here
i just love the third world destination
like
you're cool slumming it right going to a
third world well you guys are gonna slum
it we're gonna go stay in the one resort
you guys will fit right in shitty [ __ ]
and dookie honestly the people there
probably make more than you guys do yeah
yeah handsome rob though he's not
getting [ __ ] on which i love
yeah he's not even in the top poor jake
man if he keeps performing he'll make it
into that uh
he'll eat out a thing and and beat out
uh bro what's his name broke frog
that's gotta be a big motivator yeah
jake is clawing his way to the forbes
list i'm telling you guys hot dog list
we gotta do hot dog yeah i'm down how
many hot dogs you can like i'm
vegetarian
yeah sure you have i bet you've eaten
i've never eaten a tofu prep all right
well i just know they're called that
we'll put that on the list [ __ ] off with
that
tofu pup i can choke down some dogs
though for sure
we do a hot dog list but we still have
[ __ ] annual income on there for no
reason
this is our hot dog liz this is ugly
[ __ ] jake he makes 60k a year yeah
and he can eat 10 hot dogs you need to
have like you know
like a draft of some kind fantasy
friends league oh you know what it is
it's just draft day
and it's how many you can eat in the
sitting and it like guarantees your
place as
like where you are on the list so you're
either in the welfare ten of the hot dog
boys or the forbes list of the hot dogs
and your income is still on there yeah
income matters
yeah you're still gonna be shamed yeah
for not making enough
[Laughter]
good i wouldn't have it yeah this is
ugly [ __ ] uh doofus dave
he ate a hundred hot dogs he makes 25k
here so he did win the competition no we
should we should do like a list about
like what size our dicks are
okay yeah
yeah what do you guys think of nfts
you